bonsoir jean faniel et merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on en
parlait il ya quelques semaines parce
que le gouvernement le ministre de la
santé avait fait une conférence de
presse là dessus le moral des français
qui dégringolait depuis on parle
beaucoup de vaccins de restriction
comment vont les français à l'instant t
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça s'aggrave
est-ce que ça va un peu mieux on en
doute
mais bon non non non malheureusement non
aujourd'hui leur moral est de plus en
plus catastrophique est bon il y a de
quoi être abattu quand on quand on vit
au ralenti comme aujourd'hui
chacun vit terrée avec un peu de chance
il un peu il a que vaut autour de lui sa
famille mais il n'a plus aucune
possibilité de rencontrer facilement des
amis de sortir et se distraire c'est
très difficile de vivre cette vie
réduite groupe avait et je peux vous
dire que le deuxième confinement est
beaucoup plus mal supporté que le
premier alors justement a évidemment on
craint l'annonceur peut être pas demain
mais mais c'est vrai que dans d'autres
pays il ya d'autres confirmant de
deuxième pardon d'un deuxième
confinement est ce que ce serait
vraiment fatale
justement pour le moral de bon nombre de
nos compatriotes
ce sera un facteur aggravant ça c'est
évident
maintenant c'est l'épidémie progresse
semble-t-il à pas de géants donc il faut
savoir prendre des mesures pour se
protéger
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux empêcher les
gens de vives pour la les empêcher de
mourir
je pense que c'est un calcul qui est pas
évident mais c'est quand même sans doute
le confirme à toutes ces mesures de
protections cent sont sans doute les
seuls qui sont pour le moment envisagée
en attendant le vaccin est ce que vous
estimez que vous en tant que psychiatre
vous avez été assez entendue par les
autorités parce que on parle de santé on
parle d'économie mais on parle
finalement assez peu justement de cet
aspect difficile que traversent les
françaises qu'on en tient suffisamment
honte dans les mesures non je pense
qu'on n'en tiens pas tellement confiance
commence on se contente de mesures qui
ont des effets sur sur le nombre
d'infections sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations je comprends qu'on
utilise ces critères là mais il ya une
souffrance qui ne se mesurent pas comme
ça par des chiffres et ça certainement
on n'a pas de tenues assez content je
pense aussi d'ailleurs que puisqu'on
parle de souffrance cette souffrance
elle est peut-être plus du côté des
jeunes que du côté ddmt adultes et
encore plus des personnes âgées
on a fait beaucoup de bruit à propos de
la rave party et bien sûr je vais pas
applaudir ces jeunes qui ont qui en fait
une rave party
mais on peut peut-être considérer ça
comme un mouvement de révolte de la part
de jeunes qui ont le sentiment que dans
tout ça ils sont ignorés et qu'on ne
tient compte que des personnes âgées qui
sont finalement les plus visés par le
virus
aujourd'hui 20% de la population
commencerait à basculer dans la
psychiatrie c'est ce qu'affirme et votre
confrère le psychiatre serge hefez sur
europe 1 le 12 décembre
quelles conséquences sur le long terme
est ce qu'on peut se remettre facilement
de ces états je pense que la fin je ne
sais pas sur quels chiffres se basent
mon confrère
parce qu'effectivement depuis longtemps
on sait qu'il y ait une aggravation de
l'angoissé même parfois des idées de
suicide chez vous grosse partie de la
population les chiffres ont été
multipliées par trois chez les jeunes
américains jeunes jusqu'à 40 ans alors
bon qu'est-ce que de comment on s'en
remet je pense qu'on sort mais assez
facilement
dieu merci l'être humain a des capacités
de rebondissements qui sont très
importantes mais à condition que le
contexte soit porteur je vous dis que ce
sont surtout les jeunes qui sont abîmés
par cette situation
il est évident que si l'économie reprend
d'une façon satisfaisante et qu'ils
peuvent à nouveau envisager un futur
avoir une activité ou revoir des amis
reprendre une vie normale
eh bien ils se remettront très vite tout
cela mais si par contre cette situation
laisse des traces extrêmement durable
qui entravent leur leur avenir et tous
leurs projets eh bien il met
ils mettront beaucoup de temps à se
remettre parler justement des jeunes
il ya des fermetures d'écoles dans
beaucoup de pays européens
que signifierait psychologiquement une
fermeture d'école à nouveau en france
pour les enfants mais aussi parfois pour
les parents là je parle en psychiatrie
pas un épidémiologiste on est bien
d'accord et il est l'école est
fondamentale et pour les jeunes parce
qu'elle est quand même le lieu où il
fréquente d'autres jeunes et où ils
apprennent à se former à accumuler des
connaissances qui leur seront quand même
qu'il ressent absolument nécessaire et
puis bah elle est aussi très profitable
pour les parents parce qu'elle leur
donne un moment de liberté pendant que
les enfants sont à l'école on en a pas a
la responsabilité de la même façon donc
je crois que c'est c'est très important
d'essayer autant que faire se peut de
maintenir des activités scolaires
merci en tout cas jean paul millet mia
les pardons psychiatre ancien chef de
clinique à l'hôpital sainte anne merci à
vous d'avoir été avec nous